from its hub in Silicon Valley to the
incredible Industries in China and India
Tech is the modern day gold mine with
Limitless opportunities for those who
dare to innovate with its billionaires
having an estimated Collective net worth
of 2.1 trillion US Dollars it's no
surprise this Market is full of
exceptionally Brilliant Minds in our
generation so in this video let's take a
look at the top most influential CEOs
who are the movers and shakers of the
tech world number 10. read Hastings CEO
of Netflix if you've ever watched a TV
show or a movie on Netflix you've got
this guy to thank Reed Hastings
conceived the idea of a rental by mail
service when he was charged a late fee
for misplacing a rented Apollo 13 VHS it
was initially meant for all those who
wanted to rent DVDs via a website
instead of a conventional storefront or
printed catalog and like many other
great ideas in history the service was
primarily meant to solve a problem
Hastings himself faced he had no idea
whether customers would even use this
new service but he went along with it
anyway and guess what it turned out to
be a huge hit with a background in the
Peace Corps Hastings wasn't one to back
out of intimidating situations but
luckily for him and honestly for the
rest of us his risk-taking nature paid
off for the better and now we all get to
enjoy movies from the comfort of our
homes number 9. Michael Dell CEO of Dell
unless you live under a rock it's
impossible to avoid using a Dell product
at some point in your life in fact I'm
willing to bet there's one lying around
you right now that's the impact of Dell
Technologies one of the world's largest
technology infrastructure companies
founded by the American businessman and
philanthropist Michael Dell with a net
worth of 49.7 billion US Dollars Dell is
one of the most prominent CEOs in the
tech industry and someone people get
inspired by he was pretty much destined
to succeed considering how much he
believed in the hustle from an early age
Michael Dell was only eight years old
when he applied to take a high school
equivalency exam in the hopes of
stepping into the business World by his
early teens he had saved up plenty by
working part-time jobs and started
investing in stocks and precious metals
honestly who does that Dell technology
started in a residential building at the
University of Texas where Dell was
studying by the age of 27 Michael Dell
had already become one of the youngest
CEOs running a successful company number
eight Gwen Shotwell president and CEO of
SpaceX you've heard of SpaceX one of the
leading spacecraft manufacturers
dedicated to space travel and
exploration but do you know about the
woman who single-handedly running its
day-to-day operations and is the reason
behind its immense growth in such a
short time sure being backed by the
wealthiest man on Earth Elon Musk helps
but upholding that reputation is the
remarkable president and CEO of SpaceX
Gwyn Shotwell Gwyn is a businesswoman
and an engineer who knows how to get
things done she initially enrolled in
Chrysler's management training program
but her love for engineering drove her
to join the El Segundo research center
of the Aerospace Corporation later down
the road she worked there for 10 years
before joining SpaceX starting in 2002.
as vice president of Business
Development today she manages the
company's billions of dollars in
customer contracts and strategic
relations ensuring spacex's commercial
viability as a space research company
number seven masayoshi son CEO of
SoftBank one of the most powerful people
in the world and the second richest
person in Japan masay Yoshi son is the
man representing SoftBank and dominating
the global tech industry with his
incredible investing skills SoftBank is
a leading Japanese investment
conglomerate whose main business lies in
Stakes across various Technology Energy
and financial companies sown moved from
Japan to the USA while still in high
school he studied economics and computer
science at the University of California
Berkeley where he developed a profound
interest and fascination with a
microchip he read about in a magazine
while still in college soon pursued his
first business venture when he built an
electric transistor which was a huge
success masayoshi's son is a highly
renowned investor with an unparalleled
Vision many people consider son's
investment of 20 million US dollars in
Young Jack ma one of the most important
Investments of all time despite Jack
Ma's company Alibaba a Chinese
multinational e-commerce technology not
having a solid business model back then
some decided to invest in MA because of
the quotes Sparkle in his eyes as
counter-intuitive as that sounds sown is
an extremely clever man with a 300 year
Vision so I'm pretty sure he knew what
he was doing moreover softbank's 100
billion US dollar Vision fund the
world's largest technology investor has
massively disrupted startup investment
becoming a global startup machine in
recent years currently along with
serving as the CEO of SoftBank son is
invested in the world's biggest solar
project plan for Saudi Arabia which is
expected to be completed by 2030 given
Massa Yoshi's son's genius vision and
foresight it's safe to say I have high
hopes for the project and its future
number 6. Sundar pichai CEO of alphabet
Incorporated this man doesn't need much
introduction as he is a global household
name Sundar pechai makes you believe in
the power of sheer determination and
focus this strong combination can take
you places and Empower you to overcome
the harshest circumstances pichai grew
up in Madras India living with his
family in a cramped home his father an
electrical engineer at the British
multinational gec always prioritized the
education of his sons which is partly
why pichai grew up to be so tremendously
successful at an international level
pichai was a silver medalist at the
Indian Institute of Technology Carrick
per an achievement that enabled him to
earn a scholarship at Stanford
University he was appointed as the CEO
of Google in 2015 and the CEO of
alphabet Incorporated in 2019. both of
which are positions he currently holds
number 5. Larry Ellison founder of
Oracle to grow a startup with three
programmers into the largest supplier of
database software and the second largest
supplier of business applications in the
world is no small feat and you need a
man of Larry Ellison's caliber to get
the job done Ellison is a tech genius
with impeccable leadership skills and
under his impressive track record in
identifying and conquering new markets
Oracle an American multinational
computer technology corporation
witnessed the most phenomenal growth
over the years despite notable setbacks
initially the company grew steadily
until 1992 when Oracle 7 was released
which swept the market tremendously
making Ellison a billionaire as a result
although Ellison resigned from the post
of CEO in 2014 he currently still serves
as board chair and chief technology
officer number four Jeff Bezos founder
of Amazon we've all bought a product or
two from the e-commerce giant Amazon at
some point in our lives can you believe
this incredible company was founded in a
mere Garage in Seattle in 1994 although
he now owns a bit less than 10 of the
company Amazon is the name Jeff Bezos
will always be associated with it's the
reason for His stunning success and why
he still remains among the richest men
in the world Bezos stepped down as CEO
of Amazon to become the company's
executive chairman in July 2021 he and
his wife Mackenzie divorced in 2019
after 25 years of of marriage following
which he transferred a quarter of his
then 16 Amazon stake to her currently
Jeff Bezos is the owner of the
Washington Post and blue origin an
aerospace company committed to
developing rockets and space exploration
number three Mark Zuckerberg co-founder
chair and CEO of meta previously
Facebook even if you're not big on using
social media it's nearly impossible to
avoid coming across Facebook at one
point or another such as the impact of
this social networking site founded in a
Harvard University dorm room by none
other than Mark Zuckerberg along with
his fellow mates Andrew McCollum Dustin
muskowitz Chris Hughes and Eduardo
Saverin Zuckerberg developed a platform
originally referred to as facemash one
of the most impressive facts about him
is that he is an entirely self-taught
computer programmer Zuckerberg's current
net worth is around 68 billion US
Dollars and he serves as the chair and
CEO of meta one of the largest and most
popular social networking platforms of
all time number two Elon Musk CEO of
Tesla and space SpaceX Elon Musk is a
man who definitely doesn't need an
introduction the South african-born
American entrepreneur is the CEO of
Tesla Motors co-founder of the
electronic payment firm PayPal and the
founder of SpaceX one of the biggest
makers of launch vehicles and
spacecrafts but above all you know him
as the richest man on Earth currently
with a net worth of 223 billion US
Dollars musk displayed a talent for
computers and Entrepreneurship from an
early age and by 12 he had already
created his first video game and
successfully sold it to a computer
magazine he left South Africa in 1988
because he didn't want to undergo
compulsory military service and of
course the United States seems to have
far greater economic opportunities for
the young and ambitious musk his success
and personal style are among the most
distinguished in the industry routinely
giving rise to comparisons with other
Tech tycoons like Steve Jobs Howard
Hughes and Henry Ford before moving on
to my final pick here are a few
honorable mentions that I feel must be
commended for their work in the tech
industry Lisa Sue CEO of AMD Whitney
wolf heard founder of bumble Daniel X
CEO of Spotify Melanie Perkins CEO of
canva and Susan wojinski CEO of YouTube
now for my final pick I have chosen a
man who has managed to transform an
already Mega successful company into a
multi-trillion dollar Behemoth
increasing its shares by over one
thousand percent in his tenure but
before I reveal his name any guesses on
who that might be you can pause the
video and let me know in the comments
below if you got that right number one
Tim Cook successor of the renowned Steve
Jobs and the current CEO of Apple Tim
Cook is a man with the most
unprecedented leadership skills the
world has ever seen since he assumed
charge in 2011 Apple has witnessed
remarkable growth and profitability
under Cook's leadership and as of June
2021 the company made roughly 10 000 US
dollars per second I mean can you wrap
your head around how much money that is
Tim Cook grew up in Alabama and later
graduated from Auburn University with a
degree in industrial engineering he then
went on to pursue an MBA from duke
universe City before being promoted to
the role of CEO after the death of Steve
Jobs cook served as the CEO of the
company and was well known for driving
profitability and crafting complex
Global Supply chains if Steve Jobs were
alive today there's no denying he'd be
pretty happy with his successor if
you're interested in learning more about
science and technology check out the
other videos on the cards thank you for
watching and I'll see you in the next
one